こーんちは　あじしゃす
今日はこちら
バンチェムズという物を買ってみました
なんかこれ結構面白そうで
まさに書いてある通りで僕でも楽しめるみたいです
くっつくボールを組み合わせて色んな物を作れるというやつで
カエルとか
蛇さん
トミック…
タコさん
熊さん
お花さん
こういう感じでくっつく玉で色んな物を作れるみたいです
これ一応４００個入ってると
作って作り直して無限の可能性ということで
ブロックのもっとこうなんか色んなことができるバージョンというわけで
すごいオイラはね魅力的だと思って買ってしまいました
すげーもうイラスト見る限りこのガっ...
子供たちがすげー楽しそうにしてますね
開けてみましょう
出ました
すごいもうくっつくんだけど結構
なんかこういう組み合わせる系のやつって面白いんすよね
無限ですからね可能性が
これでー、なんかいろいろ作れるらしいです
説明書ですねー
なんかいろんなのが作れるよーってのが書いてあります
すごいね
これはすごいぞ
2つ、こうくっつけると　それでくっついちゃうっていう
だからこれをたくさん組み合わせるともうね無限ですわ
こういう感じでねどんどんくっつけるというやつでございます
ちょ、試しになんか作ってみましょう
よし、できました！
よくそこら辺にありそ・おぉ
よくそこらへんにあるお花です
くっつくんですよ本当に
こういう感じで、組み合わせ自由で、もう何でも作れるという
こちらの、なんだ・・・ﾁュッﾊﾟﾁｬｯﾌﾟｽ
バンチェムズ
これ、マジで楽しいやつだ
俺多分このままやってると一生終わらない
ずっとやってたくなるやつだ
ヤバい、楽しい
これヤバいわ、マジでハマるやつだ
あー・・また一人完成してしまいました
これはー
おもろいヤツやでー
僕はもっと巨大な物を作ろうと思ったわけなので
今回はこちら！
こちら、なかなか凄い(ｒｙ
全部で
ひとまず開けましょう
おぁっ…っふふｗ
うーわー!
うーわーうわうわこれっ、ちょっ…うー
はい、と言う訳で３６００個出すとこんな感じになりました
流石にこれはキモい
ちょいちょいﾎﾟﾛﾎﾟﾛ落ちるのね
気持ちいいな
ちょっとチクチクして気持ちい位だな
そこそこ重いっす
はい、と言う訳で今回はこちらのバンチェムズ３６００個を使って何が出来るのか
純粋にちょっと、普通に遊んでみます
では、いこう
まず、色ごとに分けましょう
くっつくのね(納得)
ヤバい、これ思ったよりあるな、数が
だいぶｷﾓ・・面白いっす
ｸｿ―
最初から色分けすればよかった
う～ｷﾓすｷﾓす
疲れちゃうこれ
よし、　はいと言う訳で無事全部の色分け完了しｍ…
ｷﾓー
３６００個バンチェムズがあると、色んな事が出来ると思うんで
色々やってみましょうしょうｓｙでは、いこう
ひとまず、何でも作ってみよう。
出来ました！臭いのひどいラﾌﾚｼｱ
パッと見、腐ったヒトデマンだな
つぎ、こちら！
これ、剣ですね、全く持って剣です
剣なんですけど、光をまとって、剣先から光が漏れているという状態でございます
小さなボールで出来ているんですけどこの高さになっても立つという訳で
とても優れておりますね
剣ですよ
黒がね、結構いけると思うんだよね
暗黒ブッスーダークマターみたいな色してるんで
ちょっと黒で何か作ってみましょう
はい、と言う訳で完成しました。デカすぎると多分逆に怪しいので
これくらいのサイズがリアルだと思います
割とねぇ、あの、パっと見みたら完全に蜘蛛にしか見えないので
これをちょっと我が家のトイレに仕掛けて、バンチェムズで果たして蜘蛛は再現できるのか
ちょっと実験してみようと思います。